there are scientific studies that show
having a beer is beneficial before a run
we can test that theory on saturday
february 26 with the nevada beer dash
and here tell us more is wendy forrest
with the nevada craft brewers
association and richard lovelady from
love lady brewing company how you guys
doing excellent doing great how does
this all work
you don't have to run it's not required
you don't have to run no you have to
drink you have to have fun you have to
come to the to the beer festival and so
but how are we doing you drink a beer
and you go running how does this all
work uh so it's a relay team there's
four team members each person runs a
quarter of a mile so it's not as
strenuous and and there's a 12 ounce
beer included with each leg and then
there's also the root beer options as
well too
correct and what are some of the
breweries that will be out there
participating uh so they're all nevada
breweries this features all uh nevada
made beer so there's love lady craft
house big dogs all the way up north we
have a great basin and uh able baker and
it's all we can come out and p so once
they're on they can run but if someone
just wants to come out and enjoy the
beer that that's
an option as well yeah there's a beer
fest
uh directly after the beer run so what
makes your your your craft or so special
uh gosh
on the spot uh it's my beer that's what
it is um uh
the the
depth and and
breadth of flavors
you find pretty much something for
anybody's uh taste buds i love it and
there's gonna be entertainment and stuff
what else is happening besides i mean
drinking beer you really can't go wrong
with us and running and exercises but is
there any entertainment happening down
there as well so we will have music and
we will also have local food trucks
because you're going to work up an
appetite this is going to be such a
great great event now as far as teams
how do people sign up
you can go to our website which is
nvbeer.com and that'll take you to the
ticket link and you guys have some kind
of special giveaway going on right now
as well yeah if you go to our instagram
handle we're giving away uh two tickets
and then what does does someone win
something like how does it was all said
and done we're looking for the fastest
team whoever down the most beer what
with the end of the day what's our goal
here uh yeah usually we have two
categories the fastest team and the
fastest brewery because every brewery is
going to have a team but you guys will
be competing as well yes yes but we
don't win uh
on time
normally so yeah there'll be a trophy
for the best fastest team and the
fastest brewery and where's it taking
place at cornerstone park in henderson
the weather's gonna be great at the end
of the month outside drinking beer doing
some running we appreciate you guys and
the website for people people to get
information and sign up how do they do
it nevadabeer.com i love it awesome
rocky we'll send it over to you thank
you jc it is